well congratulations
thank you what's the first thing you did
after your post game in Rio I just went
to my room and relax for a little bit no
no need to go crazy just yet maybe later
on since I guess still is the weekend
have you tweeted yet
no I haven't I it's just sort of trying
to relax just you know kind of let
everything law because it's a lot of
pressure a lot of tension for the past
few weeks so just trying to calm down
and you know just enjoy myself for a
little bit so what you said in your own
postgame press conference that your game
against God can scare was the most
number of bullets before that was eager
also high quality game I don't think in
terms of quality or was I think both of
us made some mistakes but that's the
nature of the game I mean when you're
playing in a pressure situation where
it's a very critical game and both
players are trying to win they're gonna
be mistakes just that's that's how it
goes I mean we're not computers so it
wasn't the highest quality game but that
being said it was still was the most
critical game of the tournament I think
it's the game that most people were
looking forward to from the very start
when you found out that you were playing
and I can't skate with black and they
kept around how did you feel about that
um
I mean do you get your pairings and you
deal with them that's just how it goes I
mean sure I would have preferred to
maybe of white against God I have white
against Alex owner shook but you got
your pairings and you have to deal with
that that's that's the way life is do
you think it's a significant advantage
to have the extra white in a round robin
like this semi in the extra black it's
certainly an advantage but once again
you you you're given a hand and you just
have to play it as best as you can
now in this championship build it became
pretty clear that was gonna be between
you and Donna going into the tournament
who do you think was likely ticket
you two I thought it would be God in
myself we would be the frontrunners I
thought maybe I'll Alexander shook would
have a chance perhaps Yuri seems to put
together some very good results in the
US Championships as well so I think
those were the two main contenders
perhaps but I feel like from the start
that God and I were gonna be battling
each other for the lead for the whole
tournament and in future years do you
see anybody coming up who might be able
to think time will tell it's there are
certainly some talented juniors who have
some potential whether whether they're
contenders it's just a matter of time
and see how they progress now you're
playing in the Olympiad um what
tournaments are you playing in before
that any plans before that I'll be
playing in the town Memorial in Moscow
beginning of June and then I'll be
playing a bill which will be in July so
those are two very serious round-robin
tournament coming up and it's it's just
you know a lot of strong players playing
so it'll be quite a challenge trying to
win tell us about your long-standing
relationship with Chris Wood or not Oh
Chris Chris has been my second more or
less for the past three to four years
and I think in many ways I would have to
give him a lot of the credit because as
the he might not be the strongest chess
player out there but in terms of
preparation he's very good at
understanding the way that a lot of
players think and preparing openings I
think it shows with especially with the
positions I got out of many many
openings in this tournament
um you said that you stated the chase
during this tournament what did you make
that decision I just decided before
there before the tournament to stay
there simply because I found that when
the atmosphere is too cozy too too warm
it takes the edge off and it becomes a
lot more difficult to be serious about a
tournament sure you're always gonna be
serious but but when you're kind of like
in your natural habitat away from chess
it's uh it's it's a little bit more
difficult and traditionally I haven't
had good results when I've when I've
played in places which I'm really
familiar with her I like a lot now you
probably spend a lot of times in the
world staying in hotels do you feel good
at home now at a hotel absolutely on
airplanes in hotels I mean this is
lifestyle that's just the way chat says
and you enjoy that lifestyle um
sometimes it's good sometimes it's bad
but at the end of the day it's it's a
lot better than what most people have so
I'm certainly not gonna be complaining
about it so what makes a good hotel room
a good hotel room I guess as long as
it's a big room as long as there's a lot
of space that's right that's your
criteria yeah there's also like beds
which are reasonable - so you like
flying a lot that's kind of unusual you
won't hate flying well I I'm lucky I'm
able to sleep a lot when I fly so it's
just easy to fall asleep sleep eight
hours wake up and one 'don no big deal
so is a glamorous lifestyle being one of
the top chess players in Iran um I don't
know if glamour says the word I would
use
once again it's is it's a difficult life
so I mean you have to travel a lot you
don't get to spend a lot of time around
your loved ones that being said you you
do tend to make a pretty good living
financially so there always are going to
be trade-offs no matter what profession
you're in
and you know I'm happy with where I'm at
right now and hopefully I just keep
coming better maybe become world
champion maybe trust becomes popular who
knows how to make just more popular I
mean it seems like in recent years there
has been a lot more mainstream attention
you know a lot of 60 minutes and then
the biggest chess piece in the realm you
doing the right direction I think things
are going in the right direction but the
main difficulty I think at the moment is
mainly the organization you have you
know you Fe day which doesn't seem to
know what they're doing from time to
time the events seem to change the whole
world championship cycle is a bit of a
mess so I think really there needs to be
change on that front I think also sort
of the younger generation Magnus LaVon
myself
Sergey de cardiac and the players like
that we need to sort of rise to the
forefront and try and do what we can for
us because I think we are the future you
mean not in terms of playing great chess
but also just not and off the board yeah
and so what do you think about the 2010
Olympic team compared to this year's
game um well I think it's I mean not to
sound gloomy but I think it's one of the
last chances all half probably to maybe
get a gold medal as or you know as part
of a team because we're all getting
older I don't know how many more years
got or Alex are gonna be playing but
that's that's why in some ways I
actually am really looking forward to it
I feel like this is my chance to shine
perhaps and maybe lead the team to a
metal again so who's the dream team who
do you think that 2012 team today I
don't think there's any right team per
se I think myself got Alex for sure I
think we're all definitely on the team
after that um just a matter of who who
has the best results and I don't think
there's any clear-cut favorite after
that I mean Yuri probably will make the
team I think based on this result he
should but once again the the criteria
the selection based on the ratings who
knows what will happen
so in this tournament you know they're
really key moment against gotta camps
game which you mentioned did you feel
like you had a similar situation and
another point in your career we were an
absolutely must win situation with black
um not right off actually the game that
comes to mind even though it wasn't a
must-win was the game that I went
against Gregory Kai Donna in 2004 US
Championship which I did I it wasn't
where I was playing the absolute clear
leader at the time so it wasn't
necessarily the same sort of must-win
game but I did have to win that game in
order to have a chance and so there was
a game I would compare it to it's
probably that one but overall it's it's
probably one of my biggest victories
over this game against cascade yeah so
when did you come up with 95 um I just
sort of decided at the board to play it
I I had looked at some other lines an IP
d7 is also fine but Bishop b3 seemed a
little bit unusual and seemed like a
natural way to play so why not now um
why are you often like looking away from
the board
during the game it doesn't mean that you
don't like your position when you kind
of like look away and maybe I'm just
looking to see if they're any attractive
curls out there you know in all
seriousness though there is no us down
yeah usually usually it's just because
I'm calculating mentally I'm looking at
a board in my head or calculating
variations and it's easier to do that
than to look at the board itself and
sometimes when you're playing it seems
like you make a lot of phases if you're
not
and whereas if you're happy with it
happen you don't is just like a
emotional response or I think so I mean
it's I take trust very seriously and I
think any professional any professional
trust where you you want to win you
always want to win so I sort of you know
I'm very passionate about the game and I
sort of you know wear my heart on my
sleeve for lack of a better term when it
comes to playing games you know there's
no reason not to
was there a worst moment of a tournament
where you really felt like things are
not going your way I think it was when I
drew Alec Slenderman in the ninth round
that game was really I went from being
much better on the opening to probably
drawing the game than grinding for about
78 it moves thinking I was winning again
only to find out that it was drawing so
just the emotional swings during the
whole game were very difficult know when
you combine that with the fact that god
I want his game to take the lead it it
was very difficult but you know I just
went out
drank some had a good time forgot about
chess it seemed to work out so you
actually didn't prepare that night
before gotta you really went out yeah
why not where'd you go I just went to
the Delmar Loop and how many drinks do
you have all right all right what did
you drink but what's your drink of
choice Courtney we've got a campaign
uh-huh before a game with them well I
probably drink probably some scotch
scotch or vodka now you mentioned track
the goal area what what do you girls
usually say um
that usually good nama um actually it is
generally a good thing I think
unfortunately and this is part of the
bigger problem of chesses chess isn't
sexy I mean people don't think of chess
the way that they think about sports and
so what one you know I like try to act
as normal as I can so when you're around
normal people and they hear about chess
they actually are pleasantly surprised
because they have this whole
stereotypical image of the game and of
the people playing it and it's very
important to change the image and so you
think do you think the image of
intellectual things has changed you a
little bit but people think that geeky
things are cool I don't know I mean I
think it's a personalities I think when
you look at Magnus or myself especially
we don't come across as the standard
like nerd geek who's like all into
science and math and everything and I
think ultimately it's the personalities
and the people who have the chance to
change that image the people who are you
know at the top right now that's it's
really important that we do as much as
we can for the game now yeah I know that
you and magnificent both been involved
in fashion type things and that's
something that's dangerous too oh not
particularly I mean maybe it's good for
getting girls but beyond that I mean
it's what it is FASS another interesting
so what about travel like where some of
the best places that you like to go home
for chess probably Moscow or Vikon say
just because when I'm there it's this
there's just this whole trust culture
and atmosphere during the tournaments
which you don't find anywhere else and
when you play chess which is
underappreciated by era in many places
it's just very nice when you go to
places where everyone knows who you are
where they're following all the games
and they're just always very encouraging
so those are my two top places when it
comes to chocen what if I didn't say who
is do you feel like you because there's
so much of attention to the chess club
of the main can be
do you get recognized a lot when you go
around st. Louis Oh sometimes just for
instance the other night as I was coming
back after that game against Lenderman I
was recognized quite randomly here in
the Central West done by someone I had
seen in six months so it happens from
time to time but in many ways I actually
prefer being anonymous I think that's
one of the perks of being really great
at chess as you sort of went when you're
in the trust world you are very famous
you are well-known but when you get
outside of it you're completely
anonymous and you can do whatever you
want without having to worry about
paparazzi the change the text is more
popular I like having a private life
which not everyone is prime trying to
find out things no a lot of things in
your interviews it seems like sometimes
we're on Twitter and whatnot like
sometimes you say one thing and then you
say the other things do you do that to
be more interesting or do you have an
example right off well like for instance
you said yesterday that you fully didn't
play well in this tournament mm-hmm and
then today you said that you thought you
played well which is the popular opinion
well I played well enough to win the
tournament did I believe my best no and
I mean maybe this isn't part from from
having to deal with a foreign world
champion a lot but you know when when
you play chess you should strive to be
better
you should always strive to be better
and I blew some key opportunities here
which you know maybe if if there were
some stronger players playing in the
tournament that the extra half points
would have added up and I went to have
one so even though I played well
relatively I mean there definitely is
room for improvement I think that's the
most important thing is to keep trying
to improve so psychologically what's
more important getting your rating
higher than other players or getting
into a certain barrier like 100 I think
it's just just winning tournaments
basically learning how to beat the
players it's very talk because no matter
what level you're at and chess
you always are playing against players
who are stronger than you at least until
you reach the very top so it's just a
matter of trying to beat the stronger
players learning how to beat them in
fact
at any level do you think you'll be
world champion we'll see I'm not gonna
say yes or no because I think there are
several factors which are outside of my
control if there was a world
championship match what do you think
like at this point in your playing
strength would be the most favorable
format for you probably probably a
tournament much like the candidates
that's being held next March something
along those lines but I'm still somewhat
of a traditionalist and I do like the
match system a little bit more even
though you haven't had as much
experience on that yeah but I think the
difference also is that I wouldn't treat
it like a match I mean most some of the
players that I really admire these days
just play all the openings on the board
and I feel like even in a match I would
just go about playing everything I mean
why not why not try and win with white
and black I mean there's no reason to
try and draw every game with black do
you think you have the most uh most like
a fighting style with black of all the
top players in the world at the moment
yeah but it's a it's a double-edged
sword because when you play like that
you can also lose more games than some
of the other top players who who will
just draw a game just have losing so it
it depends but you know you only have so
many games that you're gonna play in
your career in your lifetime so why not
try and make the most of it is there
anyone who inspired you in that vein um
I mean probably it could spawn off more
than anyone just his ability to play for
the four wins with both colors to get
the initiative and try and just beat
people you know do you think your work
with him had an overall positive effect
in their game I don't know I think it's
too early to tell her I noticed see how
Mick was making some comments about the
game and
you know you really like some of your
games like the finishing hands Robson
have you been following that you guys
communicate at all anymore not really I
mean I have a feeling that if I was
communicating with him he would have a
fairly different attitude about my games
what do you think he would think about
today like e 46 FR I don't think you
would have a problem with it I mean the
main thing with when I was working with
him is that he's that Gary is all about
playing the absolute best moves on the
board and so a game like today when to
have been a problem but you know a game
like the one which I blew against
Ramirez early on in the tournament I
would have heard quite quite a bit about
it and what do you think his favorite
game I'm hearing that have been from
this tournament I think probably the
game against Robson if I had to guess
just because it was similar to to a
study and probably one of the things
that I enjoyed the most when I was
working with him was some of the studies
that I did oh he had you he had you do
some studies say thank you say so it
wasn't all opening work no no what
percentage of the were my guys getting
together was like opening and what was
the percentage is more like general
training probably 85 90 % was openings I
would say about that yes so and the
other 10% was studies Studies on games
anything all right great oh no no
question do you plan to live in st.
Louis for a while
we'll see the jury's out on that one so
where would you go with your I don't
know we'll see probably New York